and then also i mean completely
unrelated but i was really offended when
i
i i bought a what was it advertised as a
coffee and i paid three dollars for it
you know it's not the most expensive
coffee but i was like all right fine
paid three dollars for it
literally dead ass saw this woman put a
[ __ ] shitty pod into a machine and
then pre
think coffee i'm like i don't want it
was it was it was it
was a little less pressure it was some
budget version of nespresso
i was like what is this you know if it's
an espresso
maybe a pizza not even an espresso you
know that's at the bare minimum
if you charging for a coffee you know
i'm not expecting much but like
if you're going to put the pod in [ __ ]
in front of me like that
literally just get the pot in front of
me right in front of my coffee really
really i was like i don't wanna drink
this [ __ ] yeah let's get this acid water
out of my face i don't want to [ __ ] i
don't want them
i'm kind of showing his privilege
clearly here yeah yeah
if it's a party get it out of my mind i
become spoiled on coffee to the point
where i just can't
like drink the [ __ ] stuff anymore like
instant coffee the thought of drinking
that now
like the the great you know the the one
in the top the next cafe once
yeah oh jesus christ i share my
privilege i don't even care dude
if show my privilege would mean i don't
have to drink that [ __ ] again gladly
look at you not drinking instant coffee
going snowboarding
it's not privileged it's called [ __ ]
taking care of myself putting that
[ __ ]
dirt water acid into my body if you're
still drinking instant coffee
i get it if you're desperate i i always
have it in the cupboard if i'm desperate
i have nothing else i'll do it yeah but
if that's your like
can't wait for my morning cup of coffee
puts acid in hot water
no don't do that you're worth more than
that don't give these don't enable these
companies to sell this garbage [ __ ] that
they call coffee it's not coffee rant
over
would you drink it would you drink it i
i don't drink it i mean that would be up
here boys what the [ __ ]
i mean you you kind of you kind of
saying what i'm thinking yeah the stage
is all yours
let the white man [ __ ] yeah but the
white privileged white man
who just came back from snowboarding
saying i've just come back it's [ __ ]
me
where am i gonna snowboard
oh my god because like the worst part of
like staying in a hotel right
is just knowing that you're gonna have
to like drink that shitty
instant three-in-one coffee you mean
that shitty coffee that you had at the
dyokon as well at camping oh
god don't remind me that's the coffee
machine in the door gun right and it
said
okay hold up though the fact that
there's a coffee machine in a real cat
is already uh
it's okay yeah yeah there's normally no
coffee usually there isn't right so
so all of us when we walked in we saw
that and the guy was like yeah so for
people who are staying you get free
coffee at the coffee machine and
everyone's like
perfect that's great tomorrow morning's
gonna be fantastic
walk up and my first red flag was it was
like
free coffee and i was like no no
make me pay please there was nothing
scarier than something that's fulfilling
because
i i was gonna be like i sleep that's
fine yeah i was i was like it's a it's a
machine
that serves coffee and you press the
button and you could hear beans grinding
so i'm just like
surely surely there must be some quality
to this if i can hear
something whirring in the machine it's
not just a pod or something like that so
i get this coffee
i drink it and i'm just like man i never
thought i would ask for a refund for a
free coffee but i'm kind of considering
it now how is it so bad though it was
like grounded coffee
i mean i don't know if it was grounded
coffee there might have just been like
beans
pretty sure they just grounded
some vacuums have like speakers in them
to to have like
sounds play when you pick up stuff like
to make it sound more it was not fresh
coffee
um it was it was like it was beans those
beans have been there since those
animatronics well once you once you uh
grind the beans they go bad like within
like
uh oh god i don't know how long maybe
like a few weeks well clearly the people
at the hotel didn't know they're like
i mean once they're in the machine
they're good to go aren't they yeah
they get pretty bad pretty quickly yeah
that's why you supposed to like grind
them when you drink them yeah yeah
but clearly they didn't think about that
they were like well there you go
unlimited supply of coffee right here
for you
find people staying at our hotel
honestly i will happily
be called privileged for just wanting
good coffee
i'll take it i'll take it because i i
remember like the most acceptable
formula
i was like okay you know i'm privileged
fine i'm not a peasant though sometimes
i'm not a passion you're fine
because like i remember like i've grown
up my entire life on instant coffee like
my my my my childhood was my parents
like drinking
instant coffee with powdered coffee
mates yeah right and that was that was
just that was just my entire life
i remember like after i finished
university you know had my first job
um you know i tried tried getting a
coffee machine for the first time
and i remember the first thing my mom
said my mom dad said to me it was like i
didn't need a coffee machine we got
[ __ ] nest cafe right here
just as [ __ ] it's it's cheap it's so
easy it's so easy
i respect myself and i'm not putting
that in my body so
so one year i buy them for like i think
it was
i can't remember if it was christmas or
one of their birthdays buy them a coffee
machine
right i'm just like mum dad try this
just just try it just give it a try give
it a go
and now every every like every few weeks
or something they're just like
son we need more pods son
where do we buy the pods it is so much
better it's like
night and day how much better it is yeah
like that's that's what i'm looking
forward to
that's what i'm looking forward to to my
new place because my old place
i didn't have enough space for it for a
nespresso machine right so i'm like
[ __ ] the curtains [ __ ] the couches [ __ ]
the beds
nespresso machine that is the first
thing on my list right now
i said this on the live stream bro i
could like i could lose my house and i'm
like can i keep the coffee machine at
least though like
if my house is on fire i'm taking the
nespresso machine when you save your
gaming pc or your or your life's work
now i'm grabbing the coffee machine
at least i can watch my house burned
down with a nice with a nice coffee
with a nice tasting espresso you know
what i mean
oh my god honestly i i wish we did
buy a uh bring a coffee machine on
camping [ __ ] the tv yeah i mean that's
what the [ __ ]
power outlet was for right if you got
the power out why would you not bring it
i think that's what the i think that's
what the power outage is honestly i get
into god's [ __ ] monstrosity of a
and i hear like and i look over to
someone else's camping lot and i see
them with an espresso machine i'd be
like
you [ __ ] 10 000 iq [ __ ]
i hate you so much right now and then he
[ __ ] froths the milk and i'm like god
damn it guys god i always thought
bringing a weak [ __ ]
bring your own nespresso machine and
milk frother that's big brain that is
really the big brand